Everyone, welcome back for the second
system design problem breakdown. The
first one was Ticketmaster.
The reception of that was really, really
positive. That was encouraging. To be
honest, I didn't know if I wanted to
make these YouTube videos. You all
really enjoyed that first one. There
were some great comments, so going to
try to keep these rolling.
I can't make any commitments, but maybe
once every 2 weeks or so, at least in
the near term, you should see a new one.
So, the one that we're going to do today
is we are going to design Uber.
So, this is the the hardest or the most
interesting, in my opinion, of the
proximity search problems. If you can do
this one, then you can probably do Find
My Friends, Yelp, etc. It has a lot of
the the same common pieces.
And this is asked a ton
at most of the top companies, frankly,
notably at Tesla, Google, and Meta.
Um
so, I think it's a great one for us to
practice.
Now, a bit about me, as a refresher, I
spent 5 years at Meta. I was an
interviewer and a staff engineer there.
And I'm now the co-founder of Hello
Interview.
And so, Hello Interview is a site that
helps candidates prepare for upcoming
interviews, largely via mocks with
senior Fang engineers and managers like
myself. And so, I've asked this question
well over 50 times, and I know exactly
where candidates of all level, from
mid-level up to senior director or staff
and principal, do well, and where they
tend to get tripped up.
So, we're going to walk through this as
if it's a real interview,
but I may periodically interject or I
will periodically interject with some
tips or frameworks and really sharing
that perspective from a senior
interviewer.
Lastly, if if videos aren't your thing,
I've written this detailed
breakdown to this problem here on
hellointerview.com.
So, you can come over, I'll link it in
the comments, and read this if you
prefer.
We also have a handful of other
breakdowns to common problems, and this
list is continuing to grow. So, come
over here and and check it out.
All right. Without further ado, let's
get into it.
Okay, first things first, let's touch on
the roadmap that we're going to follow
throughout this video, as well as the
roadmap that I recommend that you follow
for any of your system design
interviews, particularly those for which
you're designing a user-facing product,
like design Uber.
So, the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go over the requirements
of the system. This is both the
functional requirements, the features of
the system, as well as the
non-functional requirements, so the
qualities of the system.
We're then going to touch on the core
entities in the API. Core entities is
similar to what you may be thinking in
terms of data model, but it's really
what are the objects that are exchanged
and persisted in my system.
And then the API will use those objects
in order to expose the user-facing APIs
that allow you to satisfy your
functional requirements or the features
of the system.
Next, we'll sketch out a high-level
design. The goal of this high-level
design is simply to satisfy the core
functional requirements of the system.
Should be simple, just to satisfy those
core features.
And then lastly, we'll go into detail in
some deep dives. And the goal of the
deep dives is to make sure that our
system satisfies all of our
non-functional requirements.
So, this is the roadmap that we're going
to follow.
All right, so the very first thing that
you're going to do is you're going to
write down the functional requirements
of the system. The functional
requirements, as I mentioned a moment
ago, are the core features of the
system. So, these are often like user
should be able to statements. Now,
ideally, the interviewer has chosen a
system that you've used before and you
know pretty well. That would be amazing.
That would make this a lot easier. In
the case that they didn't, you'll need
to ask a handful of questions to try to
understand that system.
Now, I'm going to assume that most of us
know Uber pretty well,
and it's certainly the case the case
that I do. So, the core requirements of
the system are that users should be able
to input a start location
and a destination
and get an estimated fare.
So, this is what happens at the very
beginning when you open up your Uber
app, you end up saying where you want to
go, it knows where you are, and it gives
you a bunch of price estimates, right?
It says that for UberX, this will cost
you $32. For UberXL, this will cost you
XYZ. Now, I'm actually going to mark out
of scope multiple car types. Oof, bad
typing. Uh multiple car types, and we're
just going to do
UberX, for example.
So, just one estimate.
And then the next thing, once you get
that estimate, is that user should be
able to request a ride to be matched
with a nearby available driver in real
time.
So, users should be able to
request a ride based on an estimate.
Cool?
And then the last thing is that drivers
need to be able to accept that ride
request, and then ultimately navigate to
the user's location, and finally to the
user's destination.
So, drivers should be able to accept
deny a request
and navigate
to pick up  drop-off.
Now, there's different versions
of an Uber system design question. In
some versions, maybe you don't have the
estimated fare part. Maybe you focus
more on the actual navigation. Um this
is typically where I lead candidates.
It's what I think is the most
interesting, but know that it's not
all-inclusive. So, maybe you want to
take some moments to yourself to think
about what some additional functional
requirements may be and how you'd
additionally include those in the
high-level design that we'll get to
later.
So, you saw that I added one thing out
of scope here. It's good to clarify some
additional features that you might think
of, but you're clearly not going to do.
Um it's really important that you stay
focused in a system design interview.
They move really quickly. So, I
recommend that you focus in on at most
those three core features of a system,
and everything else you put out of
scope. Uh so, for example, some other
things that I could think of is ratings
for drivers and riders. I'm not going to
handle that. That's going to be out of
scope. Um some other things is like
schedule a ride in advance, right? It's
showing my product thinking as an
interviewer
or as a candidate, but showing clearly
that I can prioritize and focus on what
matters.
So, we'll keep it there.
The next thing that we do is our
non-functional requirements.
So, the non-functional requirements are
the qualities of the system. These are
typically like the ilities. So, it's
scalability, availability, integrity,
these sorts of things.
Now, most candidates make the mistake of
A, rushing through their non-functional
requirements, and B, just writing down
some of those buzzwords. And I can tell
you right now that's both not useful and
it doesn't help you with the design
later on.
So, for all candidates, but particularly
senior and staff candidates, the
non-functional requirements are
incredibly important. This is what's
going to dictate your deep dives later
on.
So, you want to make sure that you A,
identify the qualities that are unique
and relevant to this system. What makes
this system challenging? What makes it
difficult? And then B, that you're able
to put them in the context of this
system, and C, ideally quantify them, if
possible.
So, for example, what do we care about
in this system? Well, we care about low
latency, as we do in most systems, but
in the context of Uber, it's low latency
matching, and we can quantify that. So,
we can say maybe less than 1 minute to
match or failure. And so, that failure
would just be, you know, we give the
user a message saying that there's no
available drivers in the area.
Um
Now, what else is important? We can
consider CAP theorem here.
So, do we prefer consistency or
availability, given that partition
tolerance is a must?
Now, in this case, we actually really
care about consistency,
uh but specifically consistency of
matching.
So, we want to make sure that any given
ride is only ever matched to one driver.
So, ride
to driver is one to one, right? We want
to make sure that there are multiple
drivers who get the same ride. And for
that reason, consistency is going to be
incredibly important.
Um now, on the other hand, we do still
care about availability. We care about
availability basically everything
outside of matching.
So, highly available outside the
matching.
And this means that we're going to
minimize downtime. The system is going
to be consistently available, reliable.
We can process requests 24/7. This is
going to be an important component of
our system.
Uh and then lastly, we should be able to
handle high throughput, but again,
putting that in the context of our
system, this is in surges for peak hours
or special events,
uh like if, you know, a a football game
or the Taylor Swift concert just got
out, you're going to have massive surges
there. And so, we can try to quantify
what our surges might be, and given that
we're talking about stadiums or New
Year's Eve, surges are probably on the
order of hundreds of thousands
of requests within a given region.
All right?
Perfect.
And then additionally, we can consider
some out of scope
here as well.
Some additional things that are always
worth considering are GDPR and user
privacy,
but we're not going to go into it in
this design, certainly not. Uh
resilience
and handling system failures. Frankly,
we may touch on that a bit, but it's not
going to be the the the primary
importance of the design. Monitoring,
always a good thing to have in any
design, uh but we're not going to have
it in ours. No monitoring, logging,
alerting, etc. And then, you know,
deployment, CI/CD pipelines. Those are
other things that would be great in any
design, but aren't going to be the focus
of our system.
So,
now we have a really clear understanding
of the system that we're going to build.
Both the core features, being able to
get fair estimates, request a ride,
match them, and allow drivers to accept
or deny those requests, as well as the
non-functional requirements, the
importance of low latency matching,
consistency of matching, high
availability outside of the matching
context, and the ability to handle high
throughput. So, from here, we can move
on to our core entities and our API.
All right, before we move on to the core
entities, there's one thing I want to
call out. And that's that some viewers
might have realized that we didn't do
back-of-the-envelope estimations. And
you're right.
So, my opinion here is that in
conducting so many of these, the
back-of-the-envelope estimations,
particularly early on in the design,
like right now,
uh are almost always a waste of time.
So, candidates estimate daily active
users, bandwidth, storage, and at the
end of those estimations, they look at
their numbers and they go, "Okay, so
it's a lot."
And then they move on.
And at most, they came to the conclusion
that it's a scaled system that's going
to need to be horizontally scaled, going
to need to use things like maybe S3,
whatever it may be.
Um but they knew that. They knew that
before they started the calculations.
So, I learned nothing about the
candidate during that. They burned
valuable time in what's usually just a
35-minute interview when you exclude
uh pleasantries and time for questions
at the end.
So, my opinion here is that
candidates should forgo the
back-of-the-envelope estimations
immediately after the non-functional
requirements, and only do them if the
result of the calculations is going to
directly influence the design. So,
here's how I suggest you approach that.
When you finish your non-functional
requirements, say this to the
interviewer. Say, "I know a lot of
candidates do back-of-the-envelope
estimations at this point. Um it's my
preference that I forgo them for now,
and that instead, I do estimations
during my high-level design if there are
some calculations that I need to do for
which the result will have a direct
influence on my design. Is it okay with
you?"
And 99.9% of interviewers will say,
"Yes, that's great." You might have 1%
of weirdos who say, "No." In which case,
no worries. You'll do your estimations
then to satisfy them. But that's my
strong recommendation when it comes to
back-of-the-envelope estimations. Now,
monologue aside, the next thing that we
do here is we jump into the core
entities.
And so, you may be wondering to
yourself, "Why does he keep saying core
entities as opposed to data schema or
data model as you're probably more
accustomed to?"
And the reason is I found that most
candidates and myself, when I'm an
interviewer, I don't know the full data
schema at this point. I don't know all
the fields and all of the columns. It's
far too early in the design.
But I can sketch out what my core
entities are. What are the entities that
are being persisted? This usually maps
one-to-one with the tables or the
collections that you're going to have.
So, often times, I'll document the
entire schema and the full columns as
I'm going in my high-level design, as
you'll see me do here today, and I'll
start here instead by just bulleting
those core entities. And these core
entities are going to be useful to
inform my API. We'll see that here in a
sec. So, what are the core entities for
something like Uber? Well, I'm going to
have a ride object, of course. I'm going
to have a driver. I'm going to have a
rider. And then, this one's maybe less
obvious, I'm going to have a location
entity.
And this location entity is going to be
responsible for having the most
up-to-date location of all of my drivers
so that I can quickly match them based
on proximity.
And we'll see, of course, how that works
in the high-level design.
And so, now we move on next to the API.
And the API's goal is really simple.
People people kind of overthink this or
make this more complicated than it needs
to be.
We're going to use our core entities
in order to go one-by-one satisfying our
functional requirements. So, we might
have one, we might have many APIs per
requirement, but we're going to look at
those one-by-one and make sure that we
have the a full set of APIs in order to
meet them.
So, for example, the very first one that
we have here is to get a fare estimate.
And so, what this is going to do is it's
going to request the ETA and the price
of a ride, and it's going to persist
those in our database. And I'm going to
choose to instead of use a separate
entity, just create a ride entity with
an ETA and a price. And that ride entity
is something that we can then continue
to update if ultimately they decide to
request the ride and match, etc. If they
don't, we have some excess data laying
around, but it'll be great for analytics
to know what people are requesting and
ultimately not choosing.
Um so, this API is going to be a post
because we're going to be creating new
data. I'm going to have the ride
fare estimate.
And it's going to return a partial ride.
And I use partial here, this is just
TypeScript notation. You can use
whatever you want. This is not a
requirement for the interview. It
basically just says we're going to
return part of the ride entity. Uh
specifically, the parts that I'm
interested in are the ID, the ride ID,
the ETA, and the price. And I might
mention that verbally in the interview.
You might even write it down.
And the things that's going to be passed
into the body here are just going to be
the source and the destination.
Basically, where am I coming from and
where do I want to go?
So, we're exchanging our core entities
in order to satisfy our first functional
requirement. Easy.
Now, let's move on to the next
functional requirement, which was
user should be able to request the ride
based on an estimate. So, now given that
estimate that was just returned to us,
we should be able to request a ride. I'm
going to use patch since we're going to
be updating that same row. This could
also be put. It doesn't matter too much.
I wouldn't get caught up here. But I'm
going to request the ride,
and that's going to take in
the ride ID that was returned here.
Right? So, that ride that we persisted,
that we made an estimate for, that has a
source and a destination already,
I'm now going to request
that I get matched with a driver, and I
actually want to I want to go on that
ride. It's going to take in a ride ID.
And since this operation is going to be
asynchronous, we talked about it taking,
you know, up to a minute to match with a
driver, this is just going to return,
you know, a 200 or a status code, maybe
400 in case of failure. Um
and it's going to happen asynchronously.
Great.
Um now, the other thing to consider is
that the actual matching process is
going to require us knowing the location
of drivers. We mentioned that. So, how
do we know the location of drivers?
Well, we're going to have to have some
additional endpoint here. Maybe it's a
location endpoint update that drivers
call every n seconds with their lat/long
to let us know where they are.
Um so, that's going to be important. And
note, a lot of candidates miss this up
front in the API section. That's totally
fine. There's no expectation that you
get every single API right out of the
gate. As you're designing, you might
find more, and you'll come back and
you'll add to this list. That's totally
great. Of course, I've done this so many
times, I have the the foresight that you
might not have in an interview.
Um
so, I'm going to add it here
immediately, but just know, this is kind
of a
a moving model that can be updated as
you go.
And so, now we've satisfied the second
functional requirement. The third one is
the driver should be able to accept or
deny a request, and then also navigate
to pick up and drop off.
So, to be able to accept or deny a
request, we're going to go back to
uh our ride API. This is going to be
driver accepts.
And I'll pass in
that ride ID,
as well as maybe true/false or
uh yeah, you know, true/false
if they accept or deny it, respectively.
So, given this ride ID,
do I accept or deny matching? And again,
I chose patch here because we're going
to be updating that same row.
Realistically, this could also be a post
cuz it probably will need to create a
new row and the status or maybe update a
different status.
Um
we could come back and change that, but
I think patch is going to be fine for
now.
And then, the last thing is that drivers
are going to be navigating first to the
pickup location,
and then next to the destination. They
need to be able to update us, you know,
tell us that I've gotten to the dest-
I've gotten to the initial pickup
location. It's time for me to go to the
destination. So, I'm going to create an
endpoint for that. It's going to be
called ride driver.
Um it's going to be update.
And what it's going to take is, of
course, that ride ID again, and then,
you know, some status. And maybe the
status is going to be picked up
or
you know, dropped off.
Doesn't matter, something like that. And
what it's going to maybe return is the
lat/long of the next place that they
need to go or null if if if not
relevant. So, in the case that they
picked them up from a destination, then
we'll update that in the database and
we'll send them, "Cool. We're from a
pickup location, excuse me. Here's the
lat/long of the destination you need to
navigate to." On the other hand, if it
tells that they dropped off a candidate,
then we'll just give them a 200, return
null here.
Uh there's nowhere further for them to
go.
Great. So, this is a complete set of our
APIs. They use our core entities
um in order to satisfy our functional
requirements. A couple things that I'll
I'll note quickly, beyond the fact that
you can come back and amend these as I
already mentioned, people may maybe
noticing that I I don't put any data
types here. Um why is that? Now, if
you're a mid-level candidate or a junior
candidate, go ahead, you can put data
types. That's fine. Senior, staff
candidates, please don't. I I find that
this is a massive waste of time.
Um I see candidates sitting here doing
things like this, typing out number and
number and uh
it's borderline insulting to the
interviewer. I maybe I'm being too
flippant in saying that, but like it
it's inferred. You're a senior
candidate. You're a senior plus
candidate. We know that you know that a
a latitude is uh a number. We know that
you know that a ride ID is either a
string or a number, respectively. We
know that accepting is a boolean. Like,
we know these basic types. So, unless
you're going to introduce something
unique, like I did here in the case of
an enum, then maybe it's worth spelling
it out. But otherwise, your interviewer
is smart. They're following. They've
done this plenty of times. Save yourself
the time. Again, 35 minutes. It's going
to go quick.
Um
the other thing to mention is that
you'll notice, maybe, that I don't put
like user ID in any of these requests.
So, for example, driver accept, well,
how do we know which driver sent this?
And so, we're going to get this off of
the session or the JWT that's in the
request header. This is important for
security reasons. I suggest you don't
put something like user ID here unless
you're explicit with your interviewer
that you don't actually mean that you're
putting this in the body but it's in the
header instead. Um cuz if we did put it
in the body, then any user
could, say, request a ride on another
user's behalf by just making this
request with the other user IDs
user or with the other user's user ID in
the request body. So, good API security,
we're going to use other JWT JWT tokens
um
or or session tokens and they're going
to be in the request header. This is
something that I would speak to during
the interview. Maybe I would write it as
a bullet but not necessary.
Awesome. All right, so we got our core
entities in our API down. Let's keep
moving. Now for the fun stuff.
All right, we've laid a really strong
foundation. We've gone over our
requirements, the core entities, and the
API.
At this point, ideally, you're about 15
minutes into the interview. If you're a
mid-level candidate, maybe it's taking
you a little longer than that, 15 to 20.
If you're a senior staff candidate,
ideally 15, maybe even a little bit
less. This gives you plenty of time now
to go into the high-level design, which
we'll do now while leaving room at the
end for deep dives.
So, we're going to continue on this
theme of each section relying on the one
before it.
So, for the high-level design, the goal,
as we mentioned, is to be able to
satisfy our core functional requirements
of the features of the system.
And the way that we're going to do that
is we're just going to go one by one
through our APIs and use them
as the input flow of data in order to
design a system that satisfies each of
them. And if we satisfy our APIs, then
we've satisfied our functional
requirements because, of course, we
built our APIs based on our functional
requirements. So, hopefully that makes
sense.
Um
let's start then right away with our
first API endpoint. The first API
endpoint, again, is post ride fare
estimate
which takes in a source and a
destination and returns to the user an
estimate as well as an ETA for a
particular ride request.
So, what do we need in order to make
that a reality?
Well, the first thing that we're going
to need is a client and we're going to
have a client for a driver. And so, this
can be an iOS app, this could be an
Android app. We won't support web.
And so,
this driver
oh, excuse me, I've said driver here, I
mean rider.
So, this rider is going to make a
request
and that request is first going to hit
our
uh AWS
managed API gateway.
And so, this guy is going to be
responsible for a couple of things. It's
going to be responsible for load
balancing.
It's going to be responsible for
routing, this is the thing that it's
kind of most important. It's going to
take each incoming API request and it's
going to route it to the correct
microservice. And then it can also do
some additional auxiliary things like
authentication, SSL termination,
um
uh what else can it do? Rate limiting,
etc.
So, it's nice to jot some of these
things down. Don't get distracted by
them. You know, this this shows well for
the technical excellence axes that that
meta evaluates under and most of the
um major companies have have something
to that effect.
But, don't let it distract you. It's not
the most important thing. So, important,
I got an AWS API managed gateway here
and it's going to simply be responsible
for routing to each of my respective
microservices.
Now, in the case of this request, this
is going to be our get fare
estimate request.
Uh we're going to hit this ride service
that we'll create here.
And the ride service is going to handle
fare estimates.
And so, the real Uber is going to have
some complex ML model that's going to be
responsible for getting these
estimations. And in the interview, you
have a couple options. You could just
black box it and say there's going to be
some complex model here, this is what
we're going to use.
Or you can just overly simplify.
I'm going to take the route of just
overly simplifying and I'm going to
overly communicate that to my
interviewer and I'm going to use a
third-party mapping. So, this could be
like Google Maps.
And so, this is just going to be an API
call that we're going to make here in
order to find out, given current
traffic, what is the current ETA to get
from our source to our destination.
And then we're just going to use that
ETA in order to estimate a price, maybe
a a simple multiplication from there.
So,
our rider is going to make a request to
get a fare estimate, which is going to
hit our ride service, which is going to
use a third-party mapping service in
order to actually get that estimate. And
then we need to persist that estimate in
our primary database here.
And so, I'm just going to label this
primary database for now
for
primary DB.
Um
and this is where I had mentioned
earlier
that we're going to forego on the actual
data schema and the data models until we
know more during the high-level design.
And this is the appropriate time to do
that.
So, now we're persisting one of those
ride objects. And given that I'm so deep
into the flow of data, I know exactly
what needs to be persisted
and what should exist on this ride
object. So, for example, I know that
it's going to have an an ID, that's
pretty basic. I know that it's also
going to have a rider ID. It's going to
have a fare that we just estimated. It's
going to have an ETA. It's going to have
a source. It's going to have a
destination. Uh and then it's going to
have a status and that status is going
to, you know, start right now as fare
estimated, all right? And we'll have
some more things that we add in a
moment. And so, this isn't complete.
There's more things here and we're going
to come back and we're going to add to
it each time one of our arrows lands on
our database. We're going to see, is
there another field that should be
written here?
Um and so, then the the other thing that
we'll add, since we added this rider ID,
we know that we have a foreign key to
some rider object. This is less
interesting.
Uh a rider is going to have an ID and
they're going to have some metadata,
probably where their location is.
Um some of their payment information,
etc. It's not the most interesting thing
for this design. So, I'm just going to
dot dot dot it, which is kind of a great
tactic to use to ensure that you don't
get distracted.
So, we satisfied our first API endpoint.
Just to be super explicit about the flow
of data, the rider makes a request to
get that fare estimate. We calculate the
estimate. We persist it in our DB with
these fields.
Super easy. And then we return back to
the user the ID, the fare, and the ETA.
Fantastic.
Now, the next API endpoint that we need
to satisfy is when the user got that
fare estimate and on their client, they
clicked on it to say, "I like the
estimate. I want to request a ride." And
this is what starts the actual matching
process. And this is what ultimately
matches them to a nearby driver based on
proximity.
So, to handle that, I'm going to
introduce an additional microservice.
And this is going to be the ride
matching service.
The reason I'm using a separate service
here
oh, ride
matching service. The reason that I'm
using a separate service here is for
handful of reasons. One, the things that
these two do are incredibly different.
This one's going to be more
computationally uh expensive and it's
also going to be an asynchronous
process.
And so, by separating them, I allow them
to scale independently.
I allow them also to be maintained by
separate teams.
And that's going to be um
kind of effective
uh
for this current design.
So, now the rider is going to make a
request.
So,
request ride. It's going to hit our
matching service, which is going to be
responsible, of course, for matching
drivers
and riders.
And so, the first thing that this thing
needs to do is it needs to know the
location of the drivers.
So, we're going to have some
location DB. Remember, we had a location
entity. So, we're going to have some
location DB
and this is going to
store the location of drivers. It's
going to be just the current location of
the drivers.
And so, we can make a request here
to get
driver locations.
And this is probably going to be within
some radius. So, maybe we say
get all of the drivers within 1 mile, 2
miles, 3 miles
um
of the
drive riders. Get all drivers within an
number of miles of the current rider's
location. The driver rider driver thing
really trips me up. Anyway, hopefully
you guys are still following.
And so then this begs the question,
naturally, of, well, what about
how do we get locations into that
database in the first place?
That's where this endpoint came in,
right? Location update. This is the API
endpoint that drivers are going to call
in order to make sure that this location
DB is up to date.
So, we'll introduce now a driver client.
That driver client is going to make
periodic calls, let's say every 5
seconds now, just to be easy.
Every 5 seconds to a location service
that is responsible for simply updating
the location
of drivers.
So, this is going to be update location.
So, it's going to take a driver
location, store it in the location DB so
that the ride matching service can query
it.
So, the ride matching service then has
the eligible drivers. It's going to need
to make sure that none of those drivers
are currently in a ride or maybe
offline. Um
so, we can say get status
based on driver ID here. So, this guy
can make a call to this service
uh in order to query our database here
for a driver. And the driver is going to
have an ID. It's also going to have some
metadata like its car, its license
plate, their image, all that sort of
stuff. But, importantly, it's going to
have status.
And that status might be
in ride,
offline, or available. Uh
maybe there's some additional ones, too,
but we'll stick with those for now.
So, ride matching service got all of the
drivers within close proximity and then
filtered out those that are in a status
other than available, and then it starts
sending out requests to them saying, "Do
you want to accept this ride?"
And the way that it's going to do that
is going to be a bit abstracted in our
design, but I'm going to introduce this
notification service. A notification
service itself is an interview question.
Um so, I'm going to black box it for
now, and this is going to use like Apple
push notifications, or I believe Google
Android uses Firebase. Am I making that
up? Don't quote me on that, but
regardless, we're going to use the
native push notifications for each of
them respectively. Uh our arrow now is
going to be like this.
We're going to send a push notification
to the driver's device
saying,
"Do you want to accept this ride?"
And if they choose to accept, they're
going to make an API endpoint when they
uh or an API call when they click on it,
they're going to be calling that driver
accept endpoint.
So, that's going to be this accept and
it's going to take in a boolean. It's
going to hit our riding service, and
then we're going to update the status of
the ride accordingly. And so, one
additional thing that could be here is
of course the driver ID.
We'll call it optional because it
doesn't exist from the start. It only
exists once there's a match. And then we
would update our status to
maybe matched
or in ride, or whatever or maybe, but
something along those lines.
Um so, that's what happens when the
driver then accepts the ride.
Yes, and then the very last thing that
happens is that the rider needs to know
where to go, or excuse me, the the
driver needs to know where to go. And
so, we created an endpoint called update
for them where they tell us that the
status has changed
and we give them the next place to be.
So, the driver calls update, it updates
their status to maybe they got to the
source, they got to the destination.
Um any of those additional statuses, and
then we optionally return the lat long
of where they need to go na- next. So,
if they just got to the source, then
maybe their status updates to picked up
driver uh and we send back the
destination.
Okay. So, at this point, we have a
fairly simple design. It should satisfy
all of our functional requirements, and
we should be able to go back, look at
it, and confirm that. Yes, we can
request fare estimates. Yes, we can
request a ride based on an estimate. And
yes, drivers can accept or deny requests
and then navigate to the drop-off and
pick up location.
Now, this design is simple.
Um and it doesn't go into detail in a
lot of places where we will need to go
into detail, such as how does this
location DB work? How does the ride
matching service ensure consistency such
that there's no double matching of
drivers to rides? These are all things
that we're going to go into in our deep
dive. But for now, we should be able to
communicate with our interviewer, I have
a high-level design that satisfies my
functional requirements. Next up, I'm
going to go deep in a couple places to
satisfy my non-functional requirements.
All right, so our high-level design is
in place, and we're going to jump into
those deep dives now. Now, if you're a
senior or staff candidate in particular,
these deep dives are really where you're
going to earn your keep. This is where
you're going to show off that you have a
level-appropriate knowledge.
So, if you're a mid-level candidate,
then what we have on the board right now
is pretty damn close to what would be a
passing interview. Now, it's probably
not quite enough. Your interviewer is
going to probe you in in some places,
maybe as it pertains to the matching
algorithm and consistency, or this
location DB being sped up, maybe
sharding in your primary DB, scaling,
etc. And you should be able to answer
some of these questions to the best of
your ability fairly competently.
Um
and that's that's probably around good
enough for a mid-level hire.
Now, for senior, that's that's certainly
not the case. You would now need to go
deep to satisfy your non-functional
requirements, and you should be able to
go deep in a couple of places. You know,
aim for, you know, two places or so.
And then for staff, the expectation is
that you can go even deeper.
So, maybe in more places, say three
places, but uh the degree to which you
go deep, the depth, is increased. And
it's often even the case with staff
candidates that you teach your
interviewer something. And so, this
isn't strictly a requirement, but it's
usually a really good sign. If your
interviewer walks away and it turns out
that this staff candidate had a lot more
knowledge about, say, DynamoDB, and they
were able to go deep in some properties
of DynamoDB and how it pertains to this
particular system, leveraging their own
personal experiences, um then that's a
really fantastic sign.
So, we're going to show a couple places
where you could go deep and we could
show off that depth. We'll do more than
is needed in frankly even a staff
interview probably. Um
but I kind of want to show the range of
places where candidates could go deep
here.
So, as I mentioned, in order to inform
where we go deep, we come back to our
non-functional requirements, and we can
really just go one by one through these.
So, the first thing is we need to make
sure that our system has a low-latency
matching. Um
that's great. So, that's going to matter
in a couple places, but the place that I
want to focus in on first is our
location service, cuz this is kind of a
really pivotal and interesting part of
our system.
So, as it pertains to efficiency and
cost, for what it's worth, we need this
query on the locations DB to get near
proximate drivers to be really quick.
So, note that. And then the additional
thing along this path is that this is
going to be a lot of updates. So, we
need this
path to be able to handle the number of
transactions per second that we're
getting from driver updates.
And so, that's actually where I'm going
to start is I'm going to estimate that.
And we talked about in the beginning how
don't do math just for the sake of doing
math, and you can do it later on in your
design when it makes sense, and that's
exactly what I'm going to do here. So, I
know that Uber has 6 million drivers.
Um I'm going to estimate that maybe 3
million of those are active at any given
time. For what it's worth, that that's
probably an overestimate, but we'll go
with it anyway.
And then we had mentioned earlier that
we were going to send updates every 5
seconds. So, a driver will send their
location update every 5 seconds.
So, that means that we're going to have
600,000 updates coming into the system
every second. Great. So, whatever
database we have here, as well as this
service, is going to need to be able to
handle 600,000
transactions per second. Now, we'll talk
about later in the interview,
realistically, there's other ways to to
trim down on this,
um but let's keep that that that higher
estimate for now.
Awesome.
So, let's talk about this location DB.
How can we store the location of all of
our drivers and make it incredibly quick
and efficient in order to look up
drivers that are within some radius of
them?
Well, the most kind of obvious thing
that we could do is use some SQL
database, say Postgres. We could have a
column for lat and long respectively.
And then we would just query, range
query in order to determine any drivers
that are within a lat and long upper and
lower bound. And I guess we would have
an upper bound, a lower bound,
uh a left and a right bound uh
respectively, so four total bounds.
Now, this sucks for a handful of
reasons. The first is that the indexes
that we would build here on lat and long
respectively are B-trees,
and B-trees are optimized for
one-dimensional data. So, lat long is
inherently two-dimensional, as we just
mentioned, and so that's not going to be
well optimized. These are going to be
slow queries, non-performant queries.
And also, it's going to require us
scanning a large number of rows for
wider queries. If we have a region of,
say, 20 miles or something, then now
we're going to have to scan a ton of
rows in order to get this data. And so,
that's also bad.
Lastly, and why Postgres is is just a
terrible answer here, is that you know,
Postgres can handle maybe 2 to 4K
transactions per second. Uh that
certainly can change depending on uh you
know, write replicas, uh
optimized hardware, but let's just
estimate it's around there.
And so, if we do that, or if we have two
to four transactions per second, then
we're way off the 600K that we need to
be at. So, we can kind of consider this
out of the question. It's a bad option.
Um if a candidate proposed this, I would
probe deeper, even if they were
mid-level. It's not a great answer.
So, if I probe deeper and I pointed out
the limitations of that, then naturally
a candidate might realize two things.
One, if I'm going to use Postgres, then
I need to be able to look up these
proximity searches much more
efficiently. And then two, I I need to
somehow reduce my 600K TPS to something
closer to four TPS.
And so, to handle the first one, you
would introduce a geospatial index.
And so, a geospatial index
is something that makes querying spatial
data more efficient. And in this case,
we would use a quad tree.
And for Postgres specifically, it has an
extension called PostGIS.
And so, quad trees, the way that they
work, and let me maybe zoom over here,
and I have a little a little diagram
that I can
show.
So, the way that quad trees work is that
they take a map, you can imagine that
this is a map of the world,
and they recursively split it
into four regions. So, imagine this
first split here.
And then we make this a tree. So, here's
our root node. This region is our red
guy here, this region green, blue, and
orange
uh as you can see.
And there's some K value, in our case,
I've I've randomly chosen five.
And this K value determines whether or
not we need to recursively split within
any given cell. So, in this case, we
only have three drivers
in this region of the world, and so we
don't need to split them further. This
is less than our K value of five. Same
two here, and same two here.
However, in this region, you can see
there's a lot of blue dots, there's a
lot of drivers.
So, we can recursively split again into
fourths,
as we do here, and then bang, add to our
tree
four additional branches. And then we
take a look at each of these
respectively. This one has four, we
don't need to go further, three, three.
This one itself had four, five, six,
seven, which is greater than five, so we
recursively split it again.
Right?
And so, when you want to query, you
simply walk down this tree, and when you
get to any given leaf node, it should be
the list of all of the drivers within
that cell.
So, that's how a quad tree works, and
that's what uh is a really popular
geospatial index and one that um
you know, we can have
supported here by Postgres via PostGIS.
So, that's one option.
There's some pros and cons there. This
is going to be linked in the bottom of
the the YouTube video, so you guys can
read this on your own time as well.
So, that's great. We've now made the
queries a bit more efficient. That's
wonderful. But, how do we handle these
increased transactions per second?
Well, sort of our only option there in
this this current setup is to add a
queue here.
And this queue would be responsible for
handling all of these transactions
coming in, and then batching them to
write in batches such that we can get
the 600k down to 4k. And as you can see,
this would be some pretty large batches.
So, obvious downsides to this are one,
we've introduced a significant amount of
latency, such that our location DB is
now going to be mildly inaccurate
because we needed to wait until all of
these locations came in into a large
enough batch for us to write them to our
database. So, that's not good.
And then additionally, when we wrote to
our database, because we're using quad
trees, we need to re-index this entire
thing.
Right? So, with all this new data that
comes in, this tree needs to shift
around. This is expensive as well. It
also takes up a lot of space in memory.
So, there's some additional downsides as
to why this is an okay option, but not a
great option.
If a mid-level candidate or even a
senior candidate landed on this,
um it would be okay. Mid-level candidate
certainly passing. Senior, I'd probably
point out some of these limitations, and
then hope that they could go further.
For a staff candidate, uh I have no
expectation that you really have a deep
understanding of these geospatial
indexes,
but again, I should be able to point out
the limitations. You realize them and
adjust accordingly. So, this is not
optimized, but this is an okay answer.
Now,
there's a better answer.
And that better answer is that in order
to handle these high TPS, we can make
this an in-memory data store.
Specifically, something like Redis,
which can handle anywhere from 100k to
if it's well optimized, a million
transactions per second in a Redis
cluster. So, that's great. That handles
that issue.
And then from a geospatial index
perspective, Redis supports something
called geohashing.
And so, geohashing is a different
algorithm that's used to do geospatial
queries. And it's very similar to quad
trees, but it doesn't require the
maintenance of this additional
data structure, this additional index.
So, the way that geohashing works, let
me paste in a quick example here next to
this one,
is like this. So, again, we split the
region into fours. You can imagine this
is a map of the world. We split the
region into fours. And then we continue
to just recursively split the region
into fours again. Now, we don't make any
determination based on K, so it's not
density dependent. We just continue to
split until we get to a precision value
that we're happy with. So, in this case,
we have 01, this cell is two. If we
split this cell two again, then we end
up with 20, 21, 22, and 23 respectively.
This is layer two. Now, we could then go
again to a layer three and maybe take
this 20, and this 20 would become 201 or
200, 201, 202, 203. All right, you get
the picture. And this can continue to
happen recursively.
And so, what you end up with is a base
32 encoding of this string that looks,
you know, something like this. And the
longer the string is, the more precise,
the more that final layer is zoomed into
a smaller region.
Uh the the less long this string is, the
shorter this string is, the less
precise, of course. And you can do
things like look at just the first one
character, two characters, three
characters, and understand like the
larger region that this exists in
before you continue to zoom in.
So, this is how geohashing works. Redis
supports geohashing out of the box. And
so, the benefits of geohashing, which
are great for this situation, is that
it's easy to calculate. It's relatively
cheap to calculate a geohash. And it's
easy to store. It's just a string, and
it doesn't require any additional data
structure.
So, when you're in an interview and
you're having to make a decision between
quad trees and geohashing, which might
sound like some pretty obscure
knowledge, but for what it's worth, for
these proximity questions, Yelp, Find My
Friends, Uber, this is kind of a place
where you you spend a lot of time and a
lot of focus.
So, the question is often between quad
tree or geohash.
And the takeaway that I want you to have
is that quad tree is great for when you
have an uneven distribution or an uneven
density of locations.
So, something like Yelp, for example,
where you have a really dense New York
City, but there's nobody in the Atlantic
Ocean or nobody in the middle of Kansas,
whatever. Then it's fantastic. Um but
it's also required that you don't have a
high frequency of updates because we
don't want to re-index that tree on
every single update. It's expensive.
And geohashing, on the other hand,
is indiscriminate as it pertains to
density.
The world is split into evenly precise
boxes.
Um so, less good when you have an uneven
distribution
um or or or an uneven distribution of
densities of locations, but really good
when you have a high frequency of
writes.
So, in this case, despite the fact that
our Uber drivers' locations would have
an uneven density,
because we have such a high frequency of
writes, it makes geohashing the optimal
answer.
And so, that's what we're going to end
up going with here is Redis and
geohashing.
And it it it's worth noting there are a
couple other geospatial um kind of
algorithms indexing strategies that
exist. Uber actually uses something
close to geohashing, but instead of it
being squares, they're hexagons,
uh I believe. Hexagons? Maybe octagons.
And this solves the problem that the
distance from the middle of a square to
the outside of a square is not the same
as to one of its edges. So, it sort of
made it more circular in that way. I
think this was built in-house at Uber.
Um
So, a couple options that exist, but
these are the two main ones. The two
main ones, if you know these two in an
interview, you're totally set. If you
can weigh the tradeoffs between them
just at the depth that I just described,
you're in a really good set uh spot. So,
now we've solved our problem. We don't
need a queue anymore. A queue here would
be over-engineering. We can easily
handle the number of transactions per
second into our Redis cluster using
geohashing to then do these proximity
searches.
Awesome. Hopefully that makes sense.
Um
Okay. And then the the other thing that
I want to mention before we move away
from location is that your interviewer
might ask,
"600k transactions per second is really
high. How can we make that smaller?
Like, do we need to overload our system
like that in the first place?"
And this is a great question. We don't
have to. There's no reason for us to A,
do it every 5 seconds. We can make some
product tradeoffs on accuracy and say
it's every 10, 15, 20 seconds, even up
to a minute. Um but a more sophisticated
answer would be that we could do this
dynamically on the client.
So, the client could take in
um some information and be adaptive
or send adaptive location updates based
on things like the status. Is the driver
currently accepting rides? Are they not?
If they're not, then of course we don't
need to know their location. The speed.
Are they parked? Have they been parked
for 20 minutes? If so, their location
isn't changing. There's no reason for us
to send updates. The proximity to ride
requests or hot areas. If they're out in
the boonies, then maybe we don't need to
send their location as frequently
because we don't need this high of
precision.
So, we can put this logic Oop. We can
put this logic here on the driver and
call this dynamic location updates.
And this is going to make sure that this
TPS goes way down. I'd still stick with
the setup that we have here.
Um
But, you know, maybe we now got the 600k
down to 100k or maybe even something
smaller. All right, so that should cover
that deep dive. Uh specifically, low
latency matching under 1 minute and
optimizing for our location service and
our location DB.
The next one that we can look into then
is consistency of matching.
So, this is where we want to make sure
that no driver is assigned more than one
ride at a time, and no ride is matched
to more than one driver. So, there's two
things that we need to consider here.
Let me kind of paste those in to save
the typing.
So, for consistency of matching, we
can't send more than one request at a
time for a given ride.
And we don't send any driver more than
one request at a time. So, we're going
to handle these two separately.
So, when our ride matching service,
we're going to get that list of drivers.
And so, we have a list of drivers, list
of eligible drivers, maybe it's the top
10 drivers or so.
And the way that we can handle this
first one, making sure that that ride
doesn't send out to more than one driver
at a time, is really easy. This can just
be logic within our ride match service.
So, we can simply have a a while loop
here that says, "While we still don't
have an accepting driver, go to the next
one, send them a request, wait our 10
seconds, and then if we still haven't
matched, go to the next one, send the
send the request, etc." And this is
because a single ride instance,
ride matched instance, is only being
handled or a single ride that needs
matching, excuse me, is only being
handled by a single one of these ride
matching service instances, right? A
single server here.
So, we can have that logic within that
server, and it satisfies one pretty
simply.
I'll kind of paste in some pseudo code
in a moment that hopefully will make
that even even more clear cuz I feel my
description there wasn't as clear as it
could have been. But, one is the easy
one.
Two is the hard one.
And two is the hard one because you need
to remember that we have multiple of
these.
Right? So, in each of these cases, our
servers are are are horizontally scaled.
And so,
yeah.
You know, we have we have multiple
instances of this ride-matching service.
And what you could imagine happening is
that people just got out of a concert.
And the closest driver is the same for a
lot of people.
And those ride requests got matched on
different servers here.
And so, each of these different servers
said, "Give me who is the closest."
And in each case, it returned a list
that maybe looks like driver one and
then driver two.
And so, each of these instances, each of
these ride requests sent a notification
to driver one.
And in the case of a Taylor Swift
concert, there's 100,000 people or
whatever, then driver one is sitting
there and their phone just went
They got 100 requests all at once.
That's obviously bad. We don't want that
to happen.
So, given that we have these multiple
instances, there's nothing that we can
do on a single box because we need
coordination between the the N number of
instances here. They need to all see a
similar state that a given driver is
currently occupied.
Okay? So, what we could do is we could
update a status here. We already had a
status field in our driver. And so, we
can have an additional status maybe that
says,
um, you know, request sent.
Something like this.
And so, when we get to driver one in our
list, we would update this status and
then send them the notification. Such
that any other instance here that wants
to send to driver one, they first need
to look in our database and see was that
request sent. This, of course, would
need to be atomic. Um,
but we would check that.
And then, if the request was already
sent, we would move on maybe to driver
two because we know that driver one was
already occupied.
So, this is very similar to to
Ticketmaster actually and how we handle
no double booking for anybody who
watched that YouTube video.
Uh, if you haven't, go check it out.
But, very similar idea here. And if you
watched that YouTube video, then you see
the issue with this approach as well.
And that's that we only want to send
these requests for a certain period of
time.
We only want a request to be outstanding
for say 10 seconds, maybe 5 seconds. A
driver has 5 seconds to accept it. And
if you've ever been in an Uber, you've
probably seen this on their app. They
have a pop-up that comes on their app.
It has some loading bar that's loading
quickly about 5 seconds and they have to
click that button before that 5 seconds
or else we're going to go send that ride
request to to somebody else.
So, in this case, if we set this to
request sent and the driver doesn't
respond, they don't accept or deny,
they're just currently driving, they're
not touching their phone, whatever it
may be, then this status is stuck. It's
stuck as request sent.
And for an indefinite period of time
now, nobody else can send a request to
driver one because they're stuck in this
status.
So, we need some way to update the
And so, one thing that many candidates
think of is that they want to do
something like this. They want to
introduce some cron job,
which runs every,
you know, N seconds or minutes,
and it looks for drivers that have a
request sent.
And then we would need to have a status
update time.
And so, we would basically do a query on
this driver table to find anybody who's
in a request sent status and to see if
it's been 10 seconds since that status
was updated. And if it was, update this
back to available.
And so, this works. Like, this would
absolutely work. But, the issue with
this, just like with Ticketmaster and
maybe even worse in this case, is that
you're introducing some delta N
from the time that a driver should have
become available to the time that the
cron job run.
So, if the cron job runs every minute
and our delta here is 5 seconds, right?
We only want a driver to be locked for 5
seconds, then it could take up to 55
seconds
before we actually unlock you when you
should have been available to accept
rides. This isn't optimal. In the case
where things are really busy, we want to
make sure that we can match you to the
optimal driver to ensure that users have
the best experience possible.
So, this is an option. It's an option
that's great for a mid-level candidate.
It may even be passing for senior
depending on how well you do in other
areas of the design.
Um, but I would ask follow-up questions.
It's probably not good enough for staff.
I would hope that a staff candidate
identifies the limitations here. Um, but
it is one option.
A better option, just like with
Ticketmaster,
is to actually not do that.
And instead, use a distributed lock.
So, this could be Redis. We could use
the same instance here. I'll actually
even talk about in a moment how it could
be in the primary database, but just I
want to make this clear by having it
separate for now.
And so, we can have a Redis instance
here, which when we want to lock a
driver, all that we do is we set driver
ID with some value, maybe true, and then
it's going to have a TTL of 5 seconds.
Uh, excuse me. True.
So, this is just a key-value pair. So,
we put in Redis, which is going to be a
distributed lock in this way. We're
going to use this distributed lock to
say this driver is currently locked. So,
we'll add him to Redis, add driver ID to
Redis. The value doesn't matter. I put
it as true. Who cares? We're going to
set this as driver driver ID and we're
going to set a TTL of 5 seconds. So, in
5 seconds, that entry is going to be
automatically removed from the cache.
And so, now what's going to happen is
that anybody trying to send a request to
a driver first needs to look to see if
it's locked. So, they'll check here.
This is going to be really quick. It's
basically just a hash map. They're going
to look up that driver ID. They're going
to see, "Does the driver ID exist in my
lock?" If it does, I got to go to the
next one. He's currently locked.
Uh, but if the driver doesn't respond
now, this row is automatically removed
and the next person who reads this won't
see driver ID here and they can make a
request to the driver ID.
So, this is fantastic. It's a
distributed lock, very similar to what
we did in Ticketmaster. It ends up
working such that all of our
ride-matching services have a consistent
global view of which drivers are
available to send requests to.
Um, and it's wick- wicked fast, snappy,
great, etc.
Now, you might point out, "I have two
Redis instances now. Why don't I just
put this
stuff here as well?" You totally could
do that. Another thing that you might
want to do, which might even be smarter,
is that this could be something like
DynamoDB, which I think would be a good
choice here. There's not a ton of
relations. High availability is
important. We can scale this, uh,
largely indefinitely.
And then we can introduce in another
table,
which would be a driver lock. And this
would just have the driver ID. And you
can set in
DynamoDB TTLs
on rows on tables.
So, could end up doing something like
that. Now,
you don't need a separate Why is my text
so much bigger? You don't need a a
separate lock here or separate, uh,
Redis instance to manage. We can just
use the same database. Good
consolidation. No need to introduce an
additional technology.
Um, but we'll use this as the lock.
So, that's how we're going to handle the
consistency of matching. And then just
to make sure that this is crystal clear,
I want to paste in here kind of what
this would look like.
So, within this ride-matching service,
you would say, "Well, we don't have a
match."
Then the driver is going to be the next
driver from a list that we got from our
location DB. We're going to lock that
driver by updating the driver lock in
our database. And then we're going to
send a notification to that driver to
say, "Would you like to accept that
ride?"
And then we're going to wait our 10
seconds.
And so, that driver might accept, they
might deny. It's going to come through
this path update. It's going to update
our primary database and their status is
going to update to in ride.
And so, at this point then, no match
should be false because there is a
match. They're already in a ride. This
is ended. Everything is good here. Um,
and then of course, we'll we'll have
some way to notify the user, either by
notification, polling, or otherwise, but
I'm not going to go into a tremendous
amount of detail there.
Great. So, those are those are certainly
the two most important, uh, deep dives
for this interview, but let's let's
continue to make sure that we round this
out. I recognize that the video is
getting a little long as well. The next
one I'm going to talk about is handling
high throughput surges for popular
events. So, this one's relatively
straightforward. Uh, what we want to do
is make sure that we can scale, we can
scale dynamically in order to meet that
demand. So, if we had only N instances
here and then all of a sudden we had all
of these people who want a ride, then
maybe it's too much to be handled by
these instances that we currently have.
And we can't horizontally scale them
dynamically quickly enough.
And so, naturally the solution to
something like that, see if I can fit
this
elegantly into our diagram,
is to introduce
a queue.
And so, we can have a queue here. This
is going to be our ride request queue.
Ride request
queue. Apologies that this is a bit
tighter than I would like it to be.
Okay.
So, we have our ride request queue here.
And when rides come in, they're going to
sit on this queue. And then our
ride-matching service is going to pull
off of this queue in order to,
uh,
match drivers to riders for a given
ride. So, if we have a huge surge, no
problem. We'll be able to handle that.
It'll all wait in our queue here and
we'll just pull off when we're ready.
Our queue is is likely going to be
partitioned by regions. So, one issue
that you run into with this queue is
that if it's simply a FIFO queue, then
you might have somebody who is,
uh, the request came in first, but it's
a much harder request to match. Maybe
it's out in the boonies, there are no
drivers around, whatever it may be. And
then you could have some people who are
stuck behind the queue here not getting
matched despite the fact that they're in
the middle of New York City and there's
drivers everywhere or something like
this. Right? So, that's not optimal.
Uh,
a couple things that that that we could
do for that is that we would partition
this queue based on location or based on
regions. So, within New York City, you
would have kind of more fine-grained
regions, even more fine-grained probably
than the boroughs, but you would
partition your queue on this. In this
way, uh you don't have that problem
where somebody ends up sitting behind a
request that's taking a longer time to
match. And then additionally, the added
benefit here is that if any of these
ride-matching services go down, and
remember these are pretty
computationally expensive, like uh
they're waiting these 10 seconds,
they're they're taking a long period of
time.
And so, any of them could go down in
that minute that we're trying to find a
match. And if that happens, no problem.
We'll just pull it off the ride request
queue again, it won't have been
acknowledged as succeeded, and then
we'll continue to to match that user.
So, this works pretty nicely. So, the
ride request queue, hopefully it it's
relatively straightforward. I won't go
into a tremendous amount of detail, but
that's how we're going to handle these
these high surges.
High availability outside of matching.
So, this is where our system uh
you know, it's kind of the the
traditional answer. We can horizontally
scale each of these. These will have
their own load balancers. This was
DynamoDB, so largely it scales
indefinitely. We talked about the
scaling here from Redis, so that's
great. The last thing is that
um
we can we can split these by region.
So, realistically, we're not going to
have a single instance of this full
setup. Like, maybe this is the northeast
region that you're looking at here. And
then we're going to have a copy and
paste of this entire thing out in
California for, you know, the southwest
region. Same with up in Seattle for the
northwest region. These will be located
in different data centers. Um now,
there's probably things like users who
can travel, of course. You could go from
New York to California, which we'll have
in every data center. Maybe just a a
read replica or a copy in the primary
database of any given uh user table.
But, that's an additional way that we
can increase availability, reduce the
strain on the system,
uh make things like the queue
partitioning more streamlined and
obvious um by splitting by region here.
All right, I think that just about wraps
it up. Congratulations if you got all
the way through it. Apologies this video
ended up being a little bit longer than
I intended. Um of course, as I
mentioned, I went into more detail here
than would be required in an interview,
so I don't want anyone to feel
overwhelmed. Um just to be crystal clear
here, mid-level candidate, if you got
that high-level design and you were able
to answer questions from your
interviewer about some of the deep
dives, you're doing great. Senior
candidates, I hope that you could have
gone deep in at least a couple of these
places, the location service and ride
matching, even if you didn't land on
optimal with uh you know, the the the
distributed lock with TTL, but you
landed on the cron job, or you suggested
the queue here um with PostGIS and quad
trees, even if you didn't know the
geospatial index. Probably great, very
likely very likely a hire. And then,
staff candidates, we do have that higher
bar. Expect that you were able to show
more depth in places, but maybe it
wasn't the places I went deep, maybe
it's places that that you understand
even better than I do.
And that would be great as well. So,
don't feel overwhelmed, but I wanted
this to be relatively comprehensive so
that you feel well equipped when you go
into your interview.
All right, with that said, thanks
everybody for watching. If you have
questions, comments, concerns, anything
I did stupid that you want to call out,
please put them in the comments. I'll be
checking those out and responding
frequently. Um this was the second of
these that we've done. Again, check out
Ticketmaster if you haven't seen that
one yet. I'll try to do another one here
uh in the coming handful of weeks. All
right, thanks everybody for watching and
best of luck with your upcoming
interviews. Take care.